[Applause]
[Music]
so my friends when we think of a place
like
singapore the first thing that comes to
mind let me guess it's probably imposing
skyscrapers it's huge airport the
shopping malls or
perhaps it's elegant bay flanked by the
merlion and the spectacular marina bay
casino you might even get images of
crowds and lots of people squeeze
together after all
singapore is one of the most densely
populated places on the planet
in fact only 30 of its territory remains
unbuilt and of that percentage the vast
majority of the spaces left are
mountains
parks and protected areas so as you can
probably imagine
singapore is not exactly what you would
call an agricultural powerhouse
singapore is most likely associated with
the financial industry
trade tourism or its port maybe even
with high-tech companies
but certainly not with agriculture in
fact less than one percent of its entire
territory is occupied
by farms
obviously it's not surprising that with
singapore's rapid population growth over
the past few decades
most of its land has been used for
housing offices
and commercial space as a result the
country's primary sector especially
agriculture and livestock farming has
virtually
disappeared as an example while
singapore had about 15 000 hectares of
arable land
and agricultural activity which
accounted for three percent of gdp
in 1960 today there are fewer than 600
hectares and its share of gdp is less
than 0.02
[Music]
in other words since 1960 singapore has
lost 96
of the area devoted to food production
on the other hand this could be seen as
completely
normal sign of the times as it became
richer and richer singapore replaced
oxen and tractors with luxurious office
skyscrapers
bank branches and vaults of gold that's
right
singapore has also become the world's
leading storage center for precious
metals that are stored inside vaults
in high very high security facilities
and don't think that it was only a
strictly economic issue because in a way
it was also a political one for example
in 1984 the government banned the
opening of new pig farms because of the
bad odors and environmental problems
that they poised which is something
left out of george orwell's 1984. since
then the number of forms was reduced
from about 200 to only 22 by 1990. and
today there isn't a single one left
and friends as you can imagine this is a
dynamic that has
consequences to give you an idea
singapore currently produces are only
around eight percent of the basic food
needs of its population locally that's
one of the lowest percentages
in the world so they have no choice but
to import practically
everything they need to eat on the other
hand this is what happens in most cities
and therefore there's not really
anything wrong with it the point is that
singapore is not only a city but also
a country so its food supply depends on
international agreements
free trade deals or how currencies are
fluctuating
despite all this it must be noted that
singapore ranks
first in the world food security index
check this out
wait just a minute though because now
after the havoc wreaked on world trade
by the tsar's coronavirus ii crisis
things in singapore may be changing
[Music]
in fact the government of this
city-state has suddenly pivoted and is
put on the table its intention
to drastically increase agricultural
production using a very unusual model
but
why why does the government of one of
the most prosperous places in the world
want to revive agricultural activity and
why now does it make sense to do so is
it really possible in a city dominated
by skyscrapers international financial
headquarters endless shopping malls and
buildings everywhere so my friends would
you like to come with us to learn more
about this amazing venture by the
singaporean government if so let's get
cracking
[Music]
the return of agriculture
singapore has set itself a goal the 30
times 30 express plan that is to produce
of the food they consume by 2030 and
watch out because when the singapore
government sets its mind to do something
it seldom fails to achieve it so far the
government has already invested at least
200 million us dollars in this venture
throughout various channels including
almost 40 million dollars invested
directly by the singapore
food agency but the question the big
question is how on earth
can agriculture be developed in a place
like this well you see the singaporean
government believes that this can be
achieved by actively supporting
a new type of agriculture what is known
as agri-food tech agrotech or
high-tech agriculture they haven't come
up with a good acronym yet whatever the
name the point is that this way of
cultivation has practically
nothing to do with the traditional
methods that we all know
high-tech agriculture is a new form of
intensive or you could say
ultra-intensive farming which involves
making the most of the available space
and being super efficient in order to
multiply farm yields
if we think of for example a traditional
lettuce farm they require a certain
growing time
and climatic conditions that are not
necessarily found everywhere well
all of these limitations practically
disappear in aggregate
farms places that are more like
laboratories than the traditional
factories that we all know in these
high-tech farms the vegetables are grown
in a kind of modern greenhouse arranged
vertically on walls and rows
on top of each other they receive
artificial light and heat humidity and
temper conditions are optimized for each
crop and they are irrigated with
nutrient-enriched water
in some cases harvesting is even
automated with the use of
robots we aim to capture significant
share
of the economic opportunities in the
agri-food tech sector
okay so all of this sounds almost like a
science fiction movie or that kind of
crazy project that was supposed to a
while ago to grow vegetables on the moon
where are my moon vegetables however
believe me when i tell you that there is
absolutely nothing fictional about these
farms
[Music]
in singapore and in other countries
around the world this type of
exploitation is blooming
see what i did there and the truth is
that it has become a very promising
activity
for example this city state we are
talking about already has
31 farms in operation well in 2016
i only had 12 in recent years in fact
with a number of farms
and food production have been
experiencing steady growth both for the
production of vegetables and
also for that of fish and watch out
because the government's gamble has only
just begun of course at this point i'm
sure the question
many of you are asking is all right
grant but why have they embarked on such
a project
what are the singaporean government's
reasons for pursuing the 30 times 30
venture
why on earth have they already invested
more than 200 million dollars
in this scheme the main argument they
have put on the table is none other than
ensuring their food supply chain as we
told you at the beginning of this video
singapore is almost totally dependent on
imports to feed its population
at the same time as we also told you
this is the most food secure country
in the world the question is how is this
possible it should be either one
or the other don't you think
[Music]
well you see the truth is that singapore
imports food from a huge number of
different places in 2019
this country imported food from more
than 170 different countries
in total logically it's very difficult
to imagine that a large number of these
170 countries would suddenly have
problems supplying singapore with
everything that this urban republic
needs
but of course then the argument for
securing food supply
loses force many analysts say that the
government is actually pursuing three
objectives
at the moment firstly to promote
technological research and
create new jobs secondly to increase
quality and not necessarily quantity
particularly as regards
fresh produce and thirdly to improve the
country's image by reducing its carbon
footprint reducing food imports would
reduce the use of freight transport
and thus make it easier for singapore to
meet its greenhouse gas emission
commitments
of course on paper this all looks very
impressive but
now is there any country that singapore
can look at and say yes
it can be done and is it worth it well
the truth is
yes although it is quite far away from
this sovereign city specifically it's
here in europe we are of course
talking about the netherlands a country
that as we've told you before here on
visualpolitik has managed to become one
of the largest exporters of food
in the world food grown in advanced
greenhouses using the latest technology
but just in case you missed that video
do you need a quick reminder if so
shame on you for not watching all of our
videos but listen up because in the
medium and long term this may be the
result of the singaporean government
is dreaming of
[Music]
the era of leds and artificial climate
from the outside many of these farms may
look like normal greenhouses
but from the inside it's a different
story the dutch example is plainly and
simply impressive
since 2000 they have succeeded in
converting many traditional farms
into high-tech farms multiplying
production and reducing the resources
used
by half and all with virtually no
chemical pesticides used in the process
even in the most modern poultry farms
the use of antibiotics has been reduced
by
and that's not even the best part thanks
to this neo agriculture model the
netherlands has managed to become
measured in dollars the second largest
food exporter in the world only behind
the united states whose territory
is 270 times larger in addition the
country already has a cluster of more
than 20 universities focused on
agricultural research
[Music]
in short the dutch produce much more in
less space and a more sustainable way
and
on top of that this practice has allowed
them to become an agricultural
export power who would have thought the
dutch
[Music]
and of course at this point perhaps the
only controversial element of this whole
story has to do with the cost and i say
controversial
not because it's wrong but because let's
not kid ourselves it's something that
tends to generate
a bit of a social uproar setting up an
agritech farm requires investing
a lot a lot of money for example a 10
000 metre squared farm can involve an
investment of several tens of
millions of dollars which is obviously
not affordable for
most of us precisely because of this
these types of operations are usually
promoted by medium and large companies
and depend heavily on how the financing
channels work
therefore the more developed the
financial markets are and the less
reliance there is on bank financing the
more inclusive this model will be in
other words we are no longer talking
about the bucolic
idyllic and rural image of traditional
farms but about real food production
factories that may end up
revolutionizing the entire primary
sector you see
for the moment in the case of singapore
for example costs are slightly higher
than those of imports
in fact according to the data available
the prices of vegetables produced in
these high-tech farms are five percent
higher than those imported from
countries such as
malaysia indonesia and thailand so does
this all mean that they're
not competitive well my friends quite
the country
as you can see the difference is very
small and the cost of ultra innovative
farms is related to scale
experience and technological development
in other words if the activity is just
starting and its current costs are not
unreasonable the room for improvement is
gigantic
using our brand of quality and trust to
be able to export such quality products
to the region to meet
the growing needs of the asia pacific
[Music]
but who knows will singapore end up
replicating the dutch model in the heart
of asia and will one of the richest
countries
on earth become a major food player who
knows at this point but maybe their
efforts could be the way to avoid news
like this
10 of singaporeans struggle to get
sufficient safe
nutritious food study the straits times
in the end only time will tell
for now let's open a debate in the
comments with all of you what do you
think of these new farming models can
you imagine the future stars of silicon
valley shenzhen or singapore
planting tomatoes carrots and lettuces
leave your answer
in the comments below thanks for
watching guys we really hope you enjoyed
this video please hit like if you did
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos hope you enjoyed it and as
always
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there